okay welcome to this video playing
Michelle mission missile I know this guy
because our go puffer plate and before
pretty sure about that okay let's see
what we get here Queens Indian okay is
going for Bishop a six and be fired yeah
that's an interesting line it's
something that I have played myself very
long time ago it's quite quite
interesting to play but I always played
it with a five and Bishop c6 not with d5
I really have no idea about this line
this maybe is going he's coming with a
quick c5 not sure night 'if I've maybe
it's just an idea I better developed him
mmm 95 for f1 could be interesting ok so
I cannot take is what he's saying
because of this unprotected pieces ok ok
I can I can do this right for a form I
mean you cannot play Bishop e7 and now
if form is giving away the rook ok I
should not do that
if I go look you won I'm kind of in you
should be fun hmm hmm haha interesting
ok so maybe take this if he takes with
the Green Knight a 4 and this is not
very active ok maybe still looking one I
don't know but should be four looks
quite annoying if it hits but don't
really see an alternative if all looks
very normal yeah this intense night if
form ok so he does not really mind that
even encourages this with a queen e
seven it's a bit surprising rook e1 and
queen only seven I mean he for was very
obvious that that i was planning that
hmm
it's strange okay so what that what
happens now I'm shaking here okay but I
have some some interesting muzio I can
also take it 64 e takes f7 yeah it
should be quite good threatening it
takes f7 so it cannot save as Bishop
there I mean UK queen before that that
must be a pretty strong attack maybe not
hey maybe not he just does that this
weird and that looks but might be might
be feasible i am ok so a three and queen
what or bishop detune when i take before
with that one okay i'm not seeing much
in this game kind of a shame considering
how fishy blacks play was mmm i cannot
really avoid the Queen's right here
oh wow what a terrible game hi Queenie
Sam was really bad and I could have just
taken on c3 for a good position instead
of this this we had sacrifice ah just
bad bad bad bad hmm I just got to roots
III coming Jim I've got two pawns that
if I get the a pawn somehow I don't know
how I might tell I might be able to hang
on
check so we've he went into this this
voluntary pin because he has his chicken
Bishop before as a possibility I don't
know I can check me Bishop everyone
check probably just wins probably just
wins yeah I should have just taken on d5
how Paw stupid was that it was just
clearly bad form for white this position
I can check into sugar 14 made check
check yeah let's meet okay white resign
yes this is just made him checkmate yeah
that was just totally stupid I I didn't
really see Bishop didn't really see
Queen B form I came just after he takes
after you take so I can just take here
oops sorry and have a clearly better
position 95 and I know Brooksie one or
anything this is just very bad for black
I've got the two bishops down and he has
a very bad see pawn and okay can decide
to get rid of that but this leaves this
very week while you can let's say you
can castle which loses the exchange just
totally unnecessary but the computer
actually says that detects is six is
clearly winning why because a three here
is winning why exactly i don't see it
this this
because here queen d 6 is killing him ok
GI ok well it was pretty pretty clear
that there should be something for me
because we're Queenie 7 is frankly just
I don't know just just a bad move
getting into e four so there should be
some punishment for that so takes gym
and this was actually right which I did
take him far too quickly yeah they are
also looking many many simple some
simple things in this chap in this game
first game of a session always is a bit
tricky i know i actually didn't even see
that you can take on deform and now I'm
unfortunately unable to avoid the the
trades there and mom you don't get the a
pond and it's just lost ok thanks for
watching